help you understand the dollar milkshake
theory because you've been kind of
feeling sweating this and pushing this
for a while we've seen it you know
really play out how you called it what
exactly is that dollar milkshake theory
well so first of all I'll say I
appreciate you saying that I've called
it right I don't know if I've called it
completely right but it's on the right
track somebody asked me the other day
where they thought I was at it you know
using a football analogy and I said I
thought I was just over mid field maybe
around the 40 or 45 you know it's it's
heading in the right direction so far
it's playing out the way we thought it
would play out but this is a big game
and it's a long game and I you know I I
don't have any illusions that it's going
to be easy from here on out it's
probably going to be pretty challenging
but I think the opportunities are
enormous essentially without I'll start
at a very big picture level then I'll
try to get more detailed on the dollar
milkshake theory but essentially what it
is is I think that we're going to go
through the biggest short squeeze in
history and what I mean by that is I
think the US dollar is going to get
squeezed much much higher and it's going
to get squeezed much much higher because
despite the fact that many people don't
like it would prefer to have an
alternative that they just don't and the
rest of the world in well the US and the
rest of the world has taken out an
incredible amount of US dollar debt that
debt either gets paid off serviced or
defaulted on and the only way that that
isn't extremely dollar positive as if it
gets paid off I don't see how it can get
paid off there's just not enough dollars
to go around but the demand just to
continue to service it continues to put
a bit under the dollar and if it gets
defaulted on defaults while it make
decreased demand it actually destroys
money and what I mean by that is in a
debt based monetary system where money
gets loaned into existence a default
actually makes money disappear and it
starts a chain reaction all the way back
to the collateral which was the original
basis of which everything was loaned
into existence so even if you have
defaults where demand Falls supply Falls
even faster so whether people
continue using the dollar and are able
to service it I think that puts a bit
under it or if they start defaulting on
it because they can't pay it or don't
want to pay it we get a supply shock and
the dollar goes higher I can't figure
out a scenario actually I can figure out
a couple potential scenarios where it
would go lower but I just think those
are very low level probabilities and
because I'm so adamant about it they
were because I'm so convinced of it
that's probably why I've been as that's
why I've been pounding the table on it
as much as I have not so much because I
want to be right I mean don't get me
wrong I want to be right you know I'm
I'm in this to make money
I'd be clear that's my job my job is to
make money I want to be right and I want
to make money but one of the reasons but
if I just wanted to make money I'd just
be quiet and you know not say anything
but one of the reasons I'm as vocal as I
am about it is I think it's one of the
biggest problems existing today and I
actually want to help people I want to
help people understand what's happening
so that they can understand how maybe
they can position their pursue their
self as we go through this and even if
they don't believe in it and even if
they don't agree with it at least if
parts of it become true they can kind of
understand why it's happening and so
that's that's kind of the that's kind of
the that's kind of the genesis of the
idea that's it's why I think it's such
an important idea and it's why I've been
so vocal about it got it and I've heard
you describe kind of the actual
milkshake component of it as you know
other countries injecting liquidity and
kind of making the milkshake with the us
rather than having the ability to inject
the liquidity having a straw maybe kind
of covered the X I think it's a really
good way of articulating this plays out
yeah so I'm happy to answer that and
I'll say it's really interesting that
you asked this at this point because
over the last probably well especially
over the last couple months and
definitely over the last year I've been
accused of changing my story and it's
funny because on one hand I get accused
of changing my story and then on the
other hand I get accused of being so
stubborn and never being open to new
ideas so it's a little bit of a mixture
there but when this initially started a
couple years ago I initially I should
tell you I used to run a gold fund and
in
don't have time to go through the whole
story of why I used to run it and why I
no longer run it but essentially I ended
up shutting it down because I was not
able to raise enough capital to make the
fund structure through which I was
running it economically viable it was
too expensive for clients and I didn't
think it was the appropriate thing to do
so we shut it down we still own gold for
clients but we just don't own it in this
structure anymore and part of the
reasons I shut down is I didn't think or
I did a big big study on the dollar and
gold because I was trying to figure out
why was gold staying in this bear market
I most of my my my thoughts were that
gold should be going higher and the
dollar should be going lower and it just
wasn't and I fought it for a long time I
was very stubborn it finally I just said
to myself something I'm missing here
yeah I got to figure this out and so I
kind of did this big deep dive on my
thesis and to be honest I didn't like
the answer I came up with because the
answer I came up with was that the
dollar was going to go a lot higher and
typically in the gold world one of the
core tenets of being a gold investors
you think the dollar is going to zero
and so what what what was also
interesting is the more I studied it the
more I could became convinced that the
dollar would go higher but I also
thought the gold would go higher with it
I thought there might be an interim
period where the dollar would rise gold
would fall but I became more convinced
than ever that we'd get to a period
where they would rise together and so as
I started doing all this work on the
dollar and what I thought the dollar was
going to go get and get higher the more
I got into it the more it became clear
to me and that's when the the milkshake
analogy came up because there's this
famous movie called there will be blood
I don't know if you've ever seen it but
it's about this oil baron this really
cruel oil baron and he's just ruthless I
mean he'll just do anything to get one
up on his competitors and kind of at the
end of the movie he's talking to one of
his competitors and his competitor says
you know I'm not going to sell my oil to
you and he says well it doesn't matter
I'm just gonna stick I'm gonna stick a
straw you know across your fence down
into your ground and I'm
gonna suck it all up you know so whether
you give it to me or not I'm gonna drink
your milkshake
is essentially what he says and the more
I started studying the the global
monetary system and where I thought
capital flows would go over the next
couple years the more I can became
convinced that due to a number of
factors the US was going to suck that
capital into the United States so it
didn't matter where that capital
originated it could be on my side of the
fence to the other side of the fence all
I got to do is stick a straw down in
there to all that liquidity and suck it
up and so what I how that related to the
dollar milkshake theory that I was
talking about in in my world as opposed
to this this movie was that over the
last 10 years as since the global
financial crisis we all know that the
Fed came out and did QE in these
bailouts and they pumped the economy
full of liquidity right but it wasn't
solely a u.s. phenomenon you know the
Bank of England did it the ECB did it
the BOJ did it the Chinese that
illustrate Canada you know bailed out
their housing market so the whole world
got behind this injection of liquidity
and for the first five years we all did
it in unison from 2009 to 2014 or 15
everybody was injecting it was a
coordinated monetary policy but in 2015
for the u.s. stopped and the u.s.
started raising interest rates and when
they raised it the first time I was
pretty skeptical but when they raised it
the first time and the market didn't
crash because a lot of people thought as
soon as they raised interest rates the
market was gonna crash and I was
probably initially maybe not completely
on board that but I would not have been
surprised if that happened but when it
didn't happen that's when I really kind
of started when I said I did this to
kind of deep dive and what I decided was
that there actually was one scenario
under which we could continue to raise
rates even though the rest of the world
wasn't and so I thought that over the
next couple years that we would get rate
hikes and so that's when I started
talking about as we rate as we as we
take our syringe away and we no longer
inject liquidity we stick a straw down
in there and as we raise interest rates
that pulls capital in the United States
now that was the analogy I used mouch
most because that was the predominant
reason that I thought capital would flow
into the US was interest rates but
that's not the only reason there's many
reasons that I thought capital would
flow into in the United States one was
you know Trump Trump was a big part of
this Trump did a lot of deregulation
made it more attractive for capital to
come in he did a number of tax deals
which made it a tractive place for
capital the fact that we were growing
faster than the rest of the world or in
many other places of the world you know
look at the especially in Silicon Valley
it made a very attractive place for
capital flow and I just you know the and
because it's the world reserve currency
people have to use the dollar for
transactions it place is kind of a
natural bid under the dollar if you're
gonna hold reserves and you can hold
them and you make sense to hold it in
the dollar well then why not also hold
you know Treasury bonds or US real
estate or US asset prior stocks so for
all those reasons I thought that the US
would suck that capital into the United
States now in 2000 was at 18 I'm gonna
get my ears messed up here a little bit
maybe it was 19 anyway I thought with it
so we got nine interest rate hikes most
people didn't think we would get one or
two and but we got nine of them and you
know the whole way up people were saying
that's gonna crash the economy it's
gonna crash the economy well it finally
did and I actually thought that we would
get a couple more interest rate hikes
than we did but I was wrong you know it
we didn't get those last two or three
that I thought we would get and I and I
kind of admitted it fairly quickly I
said you know what I was wrong their
change in their tune you know Powell
kind of did a 180 stop the quantitative
tightening but even though they stopped
the quantitative tightening and they
actually started lowering interest rates
it didn't mean that we were not still an
attractive place for all those other
reasons that I mentioned and I kind of
got to a place I have this channel of
the sp500 that I've been following for
well since 2009 really and in it and
it's usually kind of bounced around in
that channel but went higher and we got
to the very top of that channel and
actually peaked our head out of
the top of the channel a little bit and
I kind of thought we'd kind of overdone
it I thought we would get a pullback now
I didn't think we would get this big of
a pullback I thought we might get a 10%
pullback I would 15% pullback I wasn't
quite expecting a 25 or 30% pullback but
here we are and now everybody's printing
the whole world is printing we're
printing but this and then people will
say to me well isn't this gonna kill the
dollar well if we were act again if we
were acting in a vacuum it absolutely
would but this is also very similar to
2009 when we announced QE 1 & 2 & 3 back
in you know 10 years ago a number of
institutions and people around the world
thought that the United States dollar
would fall as a result of that if you
think the dollar is gonna fall one of
the smart things to do is you take debt
out in that currency and as it gets
inflated away you pay it back at a lower
price later on well the rest of the
world borrowed thirteen trillion dollars
in u.s. dollars I think it was around
four or five trillion in 2008 and now
that's another ten trillion since then 9
or 9 or 10 trillion since then but the
problem is is that the dollar didn't get
weaker over that time the dollar
actually got stronger over that time and
so now we're back in the same situation
we owe a lot of debt but the rest of the
world owes 13 trillion of a currency
that they can't print and we're in a
situation where asset prices are falling
and it's crits when when we talked about
asset prices following it makes money
disappear because when money's loaned
into existence and you have defaults
money gets destroyed so now you still
have this high level of debts that need
to be paid off but the supply of dollars
is shrinking it's deflation right and so
we're going through a massive
deleveraging event right now and so now
all the central banks of the world again
are coming out and printing like crazy
and listen the the Fed is printing like
a madman I'm not denying it but the ECB
is - the Bank of Canada is - China is -
Australia is - do Brasil is - everybody
so now we're back to this coordinated
effect again right
everybody's providing liquidity I just
happen to believe that it doesn't really
matter where that liquidity gets
injected
whoever has the straw gets to suck up
that liquidity now on a relative basis
despite the fact that we've cut rates
all the way down they're still basically
the highest in the world you know other
than maybe China and again I don't think
people are racing to put money into
China right now I don't think the you
know the Russian ruble is going to
become the world reserve currency
anytime soon right so while our rates
are certainly not as high as they were
two years ago on a relative basis they
still look pretty good but all those
other factors are still attractive for
capital to come into the United States
and I think the fact that we are still
their world reserve currency combined
with those other factors will draw
capital in the United States over the
next couple years and I think drawing in
that capital will keep the dollar
stronger than other fiat currencies
despite that we're printing so much of
it